le 20 novembre 2017 il y avait eu six
textes l'humoriste qu'ils étaient que
sympathique ce texte vous risquez
faisait une blague douteuse sur le
plateau de valérie benaïm sens et que de
la télé à propos des parures
je suis un coureur s'était joint combat
n'est pas que j'aie sur les missions de
ces cas daté de valentine's le 31
janvier 2018 il présentait pour la
dernière fois cette émission les amours
car france télévisions avait décidé de
licencier
mais aujourd'hui on apprend auprès d'un
an et demi plus tard que tex dit qu'il a
été viré
pas à cause de marianne chap marlène
schiappa au mariage a pas on va appeler
donc contre secrétaire d'état à
l'égalité homme femme
voilà alors vous explique tout ça
regardez c'est ce qu'a dit c'est que si
un instant au prix et sur les lancements
fait l'écho ils vont essayer à
l'occasion d'une date de la tournée de
son spectacle en belgique l'ancien
présentateur d amour s'est exprimé une
nouvelle fois sur la sphère qui l'a
obligé à prendre la sortie de france 2
au magazine télé pro alors qu'il était
l'invité de ces que de la télé
l'humoriste avait alors raconté en
plateau une blague d'un goût particulier
sur les femmes battues qui avait pour le
moins diviser les téléspectateurs à
l'époque de nombreux signalements au
cesa avaient été faits dont celui de
marlène schiappa secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes suite à ce signalement texte
considère que c'est à cause d'elle qu'il
a été évincé de france télévisions de
façon totalement injuste selon lui elle
est derrière tout ça ou pas de son côté
marlène schiappa a réagi à ces
accusations ça c'est pas mon fort c'est
pas votre choix effectivement je pense à
des choses que je trouve mal mal
approprié je fais des signalements au
csa mais tout citoyen peut signaler un
contenu qui le choque au csa alors texte
accuse marlène schiappa d'être à
l'origine de son éviction de france
télévisions j'aime ou j'aime pas
il ya quelqu'un qui gueulait là pendant
le truc aux choses que moi j'étais
quelqu'un qui fait le marché derrière
moi alors qu'il verdès de mon point de
vue c'est toi tu te l'envoûtante on n'a
pas tellement tu as complètement pété
les plombs
il crie au complot politique à la
machination mais on n'est plus au temps
de la rtf ou le pouvoir politique
pouvait régenter ce qui se passe à la
télévision française
c'est une hérésie une absurdité or selon
montant des avis alors vous savez en
plus et j'ai reçue sera là dessus a pas
ici mais moi j'adore texte joue dit la
vérité
oui mais je suis pas d'accord mine de
rien je vous dis il avait reçu dix
pensent qu à chaque fois quand vous avez
quand vous êtes patronne de france
télévisions je vous dis que vous voyez
un tweet de la secrétaire d'état
mais quand elle a appuyé la lan rateront
quel patron de france télévisions c'est
le président de la république quand elle
voit quelqu'un du gouvernement qui
fracasse un animateur je peux vous dire
quand vous arrivez en réunion le
lendemain vous vous dites je pense que
l'on a lu un message
mine de rien je pense qu'il va falloir
faire avec textes et j'ai rien vous
savez j'ai rien contre j'ai rencontré
marc initia pas mais j'avais vraiment
j'aime beaucoup texte rien contre
schiappa contre marine sera pas aussi
mais mine de rien ça peut être bien que
oui mon deuxième 1 s'il avait été sur m6
ou sur tf1 ou sur ces huit autres choses
là il faut pas oublier que français
limite mais sut services terrestres
ailleurs il devrait être complété à
cyril je pense que ça a beaucoup par
angers delphine ernotte en fait c'est
pas mal un cha pak a pris son téléphone
mais je pense qu'en revanche delphine
ernotte c'est dit chouette super
occasion paris qu'ils avaient très envie
déjà sondé baril et que ça leur a permis
de se débarrasser de textes qui doute
qui était en bout de course selon moi je
pense que delphine ernotte en fait c'est
appuyer actuelle plus sur le tweed
marine fera pour l'événement oui même la
secrétaire d'état n'a pas n'a pas aimé
cette blague c'est pour ça comme une
chape aurait dû réfléchir un petit peu
parce qu'en revanche elle n'a pas pris
son téléphone vers la tweet est
extrêmement vite avant même d'avoir tout
lé tout les toutes les données de la
faire alors moi j'ai toujours cette
affaire lâche donne raison à theix oui
plus loin ce que fait définir note si un
homme l'avait fait on aurait crié au
scandale mais comme c'est une femme
évidemment on crie pas au scandale ce
qu'elle fait c'est du racisme anti roms
depuis très longtemps
il n'ya plus je pèse mes mots un homme
sur france télévisions elle est
attribuée en espagne at-on peur car
c'est là qu'ils n'ont pas c'est la
musique qui sort de l'est haut-parleurs
et vous mettez là
c'est un phénomène paranormal
allez-y alors oui un homme n'aurait mis
que des hommes à l'antenne on en a pas
qu au scandale mais depuis qu'il est là
il n'y a plus que des femmes mais que
des fables et prime ya plus que des
frais médicaux dès samedi soir elle a
viré tout disponible qu'à que des femmes
il ya une parité c'est même normal y
avait une parité de 12 buts de
l'interview est prévu des phares de jour
tous phares à la vie résume tout est là
tous les ordres ya bien des fois y'a
yahia et bürki requis reste une bürki
n'y a plus que des femmes ce qu'elle a
fait dans l'autre sens et je suis désolé
c'est même le rap ça marche bien marche
anti noir anti blanc ça marche dans les
deux sens chez balafon chris marquez qui
a remplacé texte cet axe par contre vous
vous êtes vraiment 100% comme ça c'est
sûr on peut pas se monter à l'est on
voit pas mais ce passé deux heures là
dessus on a quand même le droit de dire
que la façon dont il s'est fait jeter
c'est absolument dégueulasse il s'est
fait jeter comme un chien j'ai vu il ya
quelques mois à reims il était en
lambeaux
donc au moins le voir dire ça ça veut
dire qu'ils se rebellent ça veut dire
qui revient la vie moi je suis ravi de
le revoir j'espère qu'il va retrouver de
l'antenne parce que c'était vraiment pas
mal et je suis confiante par ex il avait
7 bat depuis tout à l'heure elle est
allée très bonne mère sociale